non avete idea cioè vero vorrei far
provare vi sentite male acqua vomito
sammarinese benvenuti non nuovissimo
video la challenge che faremo oggi è
rischiosissimo perché si chiama rischia
il gusto challenge come sempre al mio
fianco c'è come funziona ci sono questi
pacchetti all'interno del quale ci sono
delle caramelle queste caramelle hanno
una particolarità perché sono di vari
colori ma non hanno tutti i colori e gli
stessi gusti nel senso non è che
l'arancione è sempre arancia perché
l'arancione se vi va male cioè se ci va
male potrebbe anche essere alito fetido
quindi per ogni colore ci sono due gusti
quello buono e quello disgustoso direi
bando alle ciance partiamo subito io
spero ti prego fammi capire soltanto i
gusti buoni rosa dentiera del nonno o
fragola può anche senza dentiera del
nonno dove queste parole massaggiata la
20a ritorno beh guarda si tutti i giorni
è basato anche su tutto tutto ma è
buonissimo invece il ju rosso per
monitare no ma ti giuro non sto
scherzando si sente ma no ma è tremendo
devo fare ragazzi non sto scherzando
era disgustoso velenosa c'è sento
l'amaro grazie all'evento tolto alito
fetido rancia
non era anche non era in un arazzo no ma
tra di vomito
non so che fare o no mango e alla fine
ha capito cosa si prova poi aveva con la
puntina di di acido di quando stream dai
per favore basta cibo per cani al limone
3 2 1 bella l ascella puzzolente o
tuttifrutti di guida sono finalmente
tipo di marciume damian tutti i frutti
se vuoi puoi o sputarla bene abbiamo
quasi finita
beh allora di via libia cioè le
mussolente si trae in inganno la parte
sopra che zuccherina non finito cominciò
a mangiarla i cv che buone zuccherina
poi arrivano sia un po strana però
notare ascella noi lo senti quando senti
ok verde caccola viscida un e la
vogliamo assaggiare questa calcola
viscida la mia però una puntina di
salato in più non credo che sia mela
all'inizio mi sembrava mela ma lamela
non è salata non la prende molto dolce
lamela o che calcolano
la dentiera del nonno o fragola subito
ogni afragola sputava e acida e tremenda
questa che dopo diventa mara a devo fare
un viaggio un viaggio dei sapori
all'interno della dentiera del nord
bellissimo dai che adesso ti capito
qualcosa di buonissimo me lo sento
calzini sporchi o mora che voglia di
calzini sporchi
[Musica]
qual era la tematica sputa mio preso
calzini ma l'altra quale era un ora
faremo ora non credo l'ho letto sull eco
il tempo all'inizio sembra una roba ma
io non capisco una cosa è sicura allora
è forte e dà proprio fastidio questa
cosa non la mia e magari ci capita
qualcosa di buono cibo per cani o limone
giallo anche due è tremenda ha detto il
piano dottrinale o bidoni papa comin
grande guerra di quando da bambino stavi
male e avevi succo gastrico
no ragazzi ma vasco da cibo per cani i
mici vulcani e non lo poverini
ho un'idea divise sei d'accordo
chiudiamo gli occhi peschiamo una
caramella abbiamo indovinato che
dobbiamo esatto devo tanto ormai li
abbiamo capiti i gusti
vai
20 era niente ce l'ha come sull intera
rosa quanto ci fate però la rosa rosa
questo è dolce perché lui capitano solo
quelle buone
facciamo le ultime due perché io poi
credo di non farci a pisa continua
capitarmi dentiera del nonno vai sporchi
ma mi avete abbastanza buona potrebbe
essere una donna soccorsa sono tra gli
esempi ultima camion edoardo non ci
provare che schifo l'ultima ultima
ultima vt all'ultimo sugli utili però a
devastare doardo massima abbiano
cambiato come la mia calcola vicina non
mi over doni azzurra calzini sporchi
nuova bara ma c'è comunque poteva mica
calzini sporchi
niente siamo destinati a vendere gusti
disqus tosi il più disgustoso se posso
permettermi cibo per cani e alito fetido
lavori più disgustose che secondo
mariani è micidiale e proprio una
fucilata in bocca ragazzi vi giuro il
mio alito e pechino per colpa della rete
fra case
vorrei aiutarvi in facevano un po queste
calzini sporchi teniamo tantissimo che
il nostro disgusto vi abbia almeno
divertito fateci sapere nei commenti
quali tra queste caramelle fetide e
disgustose vi ispira di meno a questo
punto i suoi dedico quale vi piace di
più quel quale proprio non mangereste
neanche sotto tortura
se volete giocare anche voi alla rischia
il gusto challenge potete trovare queste
fantastiche bustine in edicola noi vi
mandiamo un bacione al gusto alito
fetido e ci vediamo ora il prossimo ad
ora
[Musica]